vous remercie d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct sur arte france donc cette
réunion à moscou une grande conférence
internationale sur l'afghanistan avec
les déviations américaine mais aussi des
talibans et les représentants aussi du
pouvoir afghan
que faut-il en attendre c'est un signe
qui est qu'il est parti ce qu' il ya eu
des faits dans les négociations étant
derniers manifestants les obstructions
qui sont plus ou moins identifiés et en
l'occurrence c'est l'occasion
effectivement de réunira les différents
partenaires sur sur la question d'une
transition qui ne fait pas les affaires
évidemment du gouvernement du président
sera fera ni d'ailleurs aigles à
manifester parce qu'ils puissent une
pression américaine a crû pour accélérer
le mouvement de retrait et c'est à dire
que les doutes sur le calendrier
manifestée par le président joe biden
n'entament pas la détermination des
américains de se retirer du bourbier en
afghanistan le problème c'est les
modalités pour éviter keira chaos qui
puisse être reproché aux américains mais
sur le fond on peut noter d'ailleurs un
rapprochement une convergence de vues
assez significative entre moscou et
washington sur l'idée d'un gouvernement
intérimaire à londres avant
d'éventuelles élections donc une forme
de consensus tacite en réalité qui qui
est susceptible de effectivement
d'accélérer le mouvement
est ce que vous pensez qu washington
voit tout de même d'un mauvais oeil
cette potentielle la médiation à russe
pas nécessairement ce qui est frappant
dans la réunion justement prévue à
moscou c'est surtout l'absence des
européens puisqu'il n'ya pas une
invitation faite un haut représentant de
l'union européenne
il ya il ya des représentants des
puissances régionales il ya
effectivement le effectivement le dr
l'entente aliments une dizaine ils
voulaient que la délégation soit plus
important finalement on a été décidé
qu'elle soit limité à une dizaine de
personnes les représentants évidemment
des autorités de kaboul
et puis c'est l'idée effectivement de
d'accélérer de mettre la pression pour
accélérer le mouvement de la transition
parce que il ya il ya des retards qui
sont préjudiciables et justement qui
hypothèquent le le retrait prévu
initialement par l'accord du 29 février
2020 le retrait qui était prévu pour le
premier le 1er mai prochain alors pas de
représentant de l'union européenne mais
ont fait qu antonio gutiérrez le patron
de l'onu a nommé hier un hémisphère elle
s'atténue s'arrête un français il s'agit
de jean arnault bref qu'il faut y voir
effectivement un lien avec ce que vous
venez de dire oui pour les européens
c'est un peu à camoufler parce que quand
on regarde sur le terrain aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs c'était c'était les doutes
qui a été manifesté quand il y avait une
annonce de l'accord l'année dernière par
le président donald trump
c'était l'été les européens faisait
remarquer qu'il était quand même des
acteurs importants en termes financiers
et militaires d'ailleurs sûr puisque
aujourd'hui il ya plus de soldats de la
coalition que deux soldats américains
donc il ya effectivement un problème
c'était une prise en compte quand même
ddd vue des européens qui manifestement
sons sont très très limité et c'est
effectivement ce qui donne lieu à des
interrogations et ça sera évoquée dans
la perspective de la prochaine réunion
de la semaine à l'otan justement le la
question de l'afghanistan sera pas
seulement un sujet de discussion
important pour moscou
quels sont les objectifs de cette
conférence et le règlement on
on comprend bien de cette crise afghane
mais qu'elles font les intérêts
justement de la russie les intérêts de
la russie sont pas fils convergent avec
les intérêts de des américains c'est
paradoxalement l'objectif d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un consensus sur
l'idée d'une administration intérimaire
c'est que on fera pas l'économie
évidemment de détaler long comme acteur
central de la transition en question la
question c'est les modalités de cette
transition
l'objectif c'est d'empêcher que
l'afghanistan redevienne à bras pour les
organisations djihadistes
internationales et et là en l'occurrence
en arrière plan c'est aussi l'état
islamique d'afghanistan qui visé puisque
la grand nombre des attentats qui sont
qui sont faits notamment la capitale
sont imputables effectivement à des ch
et donc l'idée c'est que faute de mieux
les talibans s'il serait une partie de
parties prenantes effectivement d'une
lutte contre les talibans en
l'occurrence puisque les deux mouvements
ne s'apprécient pas c'est un euphémisme
et donc sahel dans l'équation politique
effectivement la transition les talibans
sont considérés comme bons d'une
certaine manière une pièce centrale et
l'appel retour à la paix définitif alors
la paix c'est autre chose parce
qu'effectivement compte tenu de la
pression qui aimait partie mise par les
par les américains le gouvernement les
autorités afghanes
accès soit le président sera fera ni la
considère que l'on peut pas imposer
on peut pas imposer une solution aux
afghans que c'est aux arts ont décidé
notamment qu'une élection est donc là il
ya effectivement il va y avoir un
télescopage est certain elle laisse
entendre que si effectivement on remet
en question un certain nombre d'acquis
depuis elle qui depuis 2001 notamment
pour le droit le droit des femmes le la
question du droit de vote qui est que
les talibans ne valide pas ça c'est
potentiellement ça sera effectivement un
vecteur de retour à une guerre civile et
donc effectivement l'horizon de la paix
n'est pas encore assurée loin de là
merci beaucoup
rouse je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris rédacteur en
chef de la revue orient stratégique